hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
all enjoy your finale pie these are
going to be my season seven predictions
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the season yet
I'll also address what's going on this
summer too there is new stuff happening
this summer they did a couple clear
things to foreshadow big events like a
big war between Daenerys and Cersei but
I just tried to look at it from
different region like you know stuff
that's going on up in the north stuff
that's going on in the Crown lands and
stuff that's going on in the South so
that's kind of how I divided these up so
starting up in the north of course I'm
expecting more little bear just being
amazing the actress herself is actually
probably a little bit older but if you
remember how much bran changed
physically just because of how much
older the actor got year to year I think
if they can make you forget how much
older bran looks this season than he has
in previous seasons and they can do the
same thing for the little bear
so expecting more really awesome moments
I call the actions like this she's just
really strong leader and it's also
really funny because she's this little
ten-year-old girl with a bunch of old
men so mass respect for the little bear
on the flip side of that you know the
people who aren't such big supporters of
Jon Snow Littlefinger probably going to
continue to scheme and plot behind his
back try to rope Sansa in even though it
doesn't seem like it's sonses intention
to go against her brother he's probably
going to try and twist her against him
or at least involve her and some of his
schemes remember how committed he is to
his idea of sitting on the Iron Throne
with Sansa beside him he's not just
going to give that up just because Jon
Snow was named king in the north
so what about bran we left him at that
weirwood the weirwood that he was
touching is actually the one where Jon
Snow and all the other Night's Watch
take their oaths there's still a lot of
moments that he has not flashback to yet
we haven't got a Rhaegar specific
flashback yet it would be amazing
if we got to see the Battle of the
Trident in the moment of his death as he
whispers Liana's name you know rubies
flying from his chest it's this really
iconic moment from the books and we
haven't seen Rhaegar yet it just said
that on his death as Robert had smashed
him with his Warhammer and was killing
him he whispered a woman's name but we
never learned that name now we know he
was probably whispering Liana's name and
if you're wondering what Liana was
whispering to Ned she was just
whispering John's name the reason they
did that the reason they made it hard to
hear is because they wanted to tell you
that visually
with the transition like you can kind of
make out protect him Ned Robert will
kill him so she's talking about the bit
you know protect the baby so there are a
lot of people that were confused like
hey maybe John Snow has a different name
maybe it's like Aegon or maybe he has a
Targaryen no I think that the name that
Liana initially gave him was John and so
that's what Ned called him I don't think
that Ned gave him a different name other
than snow like Ned named him Snow as his
bastard and that was the lie but I don't
think that they were lying about his
name being John there were a lot of
people that were wondering that as part
of tradition you know maybe they would
have given him a name from the Targaryen
family tree or something from the stark
family tree like Brandon is a common
name in the stark family there were many
different Brandon's like Brandon's the
Builder it's just a lot of people were
wondering if maybe lianna had done the
same thing and given him a family name
from the Starks or maybe he had a
Targaryen name but at the end of the day
I still think that his true name is John
it's just that the last name is the big
reveal the big surprise like oh he's the
son of a Stark in a Targaryen
so technically you would call him John
Targaryen but he identifies as Stark
remember he doesn't know who his mother
is so he still thinks that he's Ned's
son so he feels like he's a stark that's
been his family his whole life so even
if everyone were to find out that he's a
Targaryen maybe he has a legitimate
claim to the Iron Throne
he would still tell you that he's a
stark of Winterfell he doesn't know
anything about Targaryens he prot even
if he met Daenerys they probably
wouldn't feel like family he's like I've
never met you before I've never met any
Targaryen I've only known Starks so
that's my family so if he had the power
to give himself his own name he would
probably take the stark name but that's
another thing too I don't think that Jon
Snow is going to learn his heritage
until he meets with bran which will not
be right away
first bran is going to learn more about
what's going on with the night's king
the magic of the wall benjin kind of
explained the magic like the dead cannot
pass here so I cannot pass so bran will
explore his powers more probably
flashback you know hopefully to a
Rhaegar scene and then he'll find a way
to communicate with the Nights Watch and
then Jon Snow largely the priority in
the north is rallying to prepare for the
night King John probably isn't going to
be too worried about what's going on in
the south because physically the north
is so far away from what's going on like
they just made it through the Battle of
the bastards everyone swore fealty to
the king in the north so Jon Snow is now
like okay great you're listening to me
we have this big problem north of the
wall let's get ready for this
so yes what's going on in the south
between Cersei and what's going to
happen with Daenerys is going to be too
big to ignore so they'll probably find
out about it but Jon Snow probably won't
send troops south I'm expecting that
he'll largely just be paying attention
to what's going on north of the wall it
was this kind of funny offhanded comment
that Daenerys made when she was breaking
up with Daario where he's like you're
gonna have to get married who you gonna
get married to and she's like I don't
know you know I'm going to have to make
an alliance I'll probably have to get
married as part of that think about this
there are no eligible Martell bachelors
there are no eligible tyrell bachelors
either so you look at King's Landing
Jamie is unattached but the problem is
is that Cersei is not going to give up
the crown so she's probably not going to
okay a marriage between Jamie and
Daenerys meaning that Jon Snow king of
the north
King Crow is the most eligible bachelor
in the Seven Kingdoms so I'm not really
expecting anybody to get married anytime
soon like Jon Snow if you asked him
about marriage he'd be like what what
are you talking about I have no idea
what's going on Daenerys isn't in a rush
to get married either
Cersei is definitely never getting
married again if there's any alliances
that are forged with marriages I'm not
expecting that to happen till season a
so those are the only circumstances
where I see Jon Snow ending up with
Daenerys form an alliance in season
eight but this is mostly a season seven
video so the takeaway for season seven
is is that no one is probably gonna get
married what about the Crown lands
what's going on with Cersei so she's
pretty much solidified her power she'll
probably squash anybody that rises up
but there are no sons of the harpy and
Kings Landing anymore that was what the
faith militant was they've largely been
killed off and the queen of thorns made
this really interesting threat when the
faith through Margaery and Loras into
prison she said we control the grain we
will cut it off we will starve King's
Landing out if you don't release them in
the high sparrows answer to that was we
are the poor we are the many you are the
few we will rise up and tear you down
now that they're dead the Queen of
thorns is free to make good on that
threat and if she's trying to kill
Cersei if she's trying to destroy the
Brown then the easiest way to do that
would be to starve them out then when
they're on the edge of death March
Daenerys azar Mian so I'm expecting
multi-pronged attack from the new
alliance in the south from the the
Dornish Tyrell of Daenerys alliance
where the Queen of thorns starves King's
Landing out over the course of a couple
episodes weakens them then Daenerys is
army can march in and it'll be much
easier for them to take the city so what
about Jaime Queen Slayer I'm not
expecting any kind of Queen Slayer
moment till at least season 8 because
all the actors just renegotiated their
contracts they're getting a half a
million dollars per episode so at least
the five main actors and that includes
all three Lannister children so Cersei
Jaime and Tyrion all getting a half a
million dollars per episode through
season eight meaning that we'll probably
see Cersei make it to season eight so if
there's a queen Slayer moment it
probably won't come for a long time and
I kind of said this during my episode 10
video last night but I think they might
give that kill to Arya because while all
this is going on you know these three
sections of the kingdom you have
Daenerys alliance in the south
Cersei in the middle in the Crown lands
in John up in the north
I think Arya is going to be skipping
around crossing names off her list but
in order to do that she'd have to head
south and when she said she was going
back to Westeros she said she was going
home so it's possible she could go to
Winterfell but it feels like she would
run into the Hound maybe and then get
pulled away in another direction
it just feels too easy to have a stark
reunion right away when season 7 picks
up so yes I do think that Arya will see
Sansa and Jon again but maybe not right
away it feels like it'd be too easy to
do that right away I'd rather see Sansa
get letters get word of what Arya is
doing and just kind of chuckled to
herself because she's kind of dark she
could just laugh the way she laughed
when Brienne told her about Arya I saw
your sister Lady Sansa she didn't look
like a lady at all she you know she was
covered in mud she had a sword with her
in Santa was like yeah that sounds like
Arya so I'm expecting more moments like
that
Walder Frey was assassinated after
eating a pie that his relatives had been
baked into oh that sounds like Arya
bacon Frey pies
so the other big thing critical pieces
of information that they need they need
to learn how to make more dragonglass
they need to learn how to make more
wildfire just everyone in general anyone
that's going to survive to fight the war
for the dawn that is where
samwell in the Citadel comes in
dragonglass would be the first go to and
then he'll probably be the reason that
Jon Snow starts thinking about Daenerys
more seriously like oh we need dragon
fire to nurse has dragons okay John
you're going to have to find a way to
form an alliance with this Daenerys
person and so then they'll have to
figure that out but that seems more like
a season a thing so I'm not expecting a
ton of Samwell in season 7 just a couple
moments just seeing him studying in the
library learning things that are
important for fighting the night king
and finally what about the episode count
so I feel like everybody has heard that
they're going to do a shortened run but
the actual episode count hasn't been
confirmed yet what it sounds like is
going to happen is there'll be seven
episodes in season seven there'll be a
little bit longer than normal episodes
so the actual runtime of this season
will be a little bit less but you won't
be missing out on as much content as you
think like each episode itself will be
much longer and then the final season
might only end up being six episodes but
but again they'd be much longer episodes
so they'd be spending as much money as
they do on each season it's just that
they'll be cramming all that into a
fewer number of episodes so nothing is
confirmed yet like their big priority
right now is getting the actors to sign
all their contracts once they do that
they'll figure the season out figure the
budget out all that stuff and then I'll
do a video explaining what's going to
happen HBO is usually really good about
announcing details like that like
they'll be X number of episodes we're
going to premiere around this time of
the year the premiere date can fluctuate
depending on stuff that happens
throughout the year so hopefully they'll
do that when they come to Comic Con they
haven't announced a comic-con panel
officially yet but I think they'll come
back hopefully they will bring the
little bear it would be amazing to see
her march out on stage and do like a
low-key style call to action where she
just does like this King in the North
speech and then introduces Jon Snow and
all the other actors come out think
about how much easier it is for HBO to
do that panel this year now that we
don't have a big Jon Snow type
cliffhanger but if you didn't know Comic
Con is going to be like the third I
think it's the third of the last weekend
in July so it's not for at least another
month but of course I'll be doing videos
for Game of Thrones all summer during
the offseason we don't have an official
drop date for winds of winter the book
but whenever that drops I'll do book
videos too so be sure to subscribe to
get everything I will continue to do
giveaways each week in MO
so my Game of Thrones bonus videos will
post on Sundays but if there's like a
big thing that happens during the middle
of the week up I'll post it during the
middle of the week you guys understand
so what's going to happen next is I'll
post my Q&A videos leave all your
questions and I'll actually just because
so much stuff is happening and I'm so
happy about the way the season went down
I'm going to speed the giveaway up so
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner
Jerry Garza you win a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details that's just on the
about page and I'll start a new round of
the giveaway now and announce that
winner when I post the Q&A video so it's
like a double giveaway this week so you
have to do to enter that is just be a
subscriber leave a comment in this video
you guys know the drill
so QA coming later this week and let me
know what kind of bonus videos you guys
want in the offseason so get hyped it's
going to be a really good summer so why
you guys enjoy your pie this summer you
can click here for my finale video from
last night and you can click here to
learn a little bit more about why it was
such a big deal the Jon Snow's parentage
being secret so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you